Noch schnell drei dienstliche e mails abends auf dem sofa schreiben und morgens beim frühstück auch schon den kollegen am telefon
haben das alles ist in vielen branchen realität moderne und innovative firmen sind schon längst von der klassischen 40 stundenwoche
Abgewichen und lassen ihre angestellten und angestellten maximal fünf stunden am tag ins büro
kommen
Urlaub gibt es wann und wie viel man möchte
Ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt jetzt alle facts zur arbeit der zukunft herzlich willkommen bei glee zum science fiction
los geht's
Die grenze zwischen arbeit und freizeit in vielen branchen wie beispielsweise
im it- oder medienbereich schon längst nicht mehr klar definiert der chef erwartet dass man auch nach feierabend
seine mails checkt und zu hochzeiten auch nachts
Im büro sitzt und das projekt weiter vorantreibt dafür gibt es dann
Ausgleichs tage oder mehr geld doch wer schreibt sich wirklich über stunden auf wenn er daheim auf dem sofa mails von kollegen und kolleginnen
beantwortet wenn auch nach feierabend noch weiter an der neuen kampagne gearbeitet wird doch
Genau das die realität in der arbeitswelt sehen statistiken offensichtlich nicht immer wieder gibt es die forderung von verschiedenen seiten
dass der achtstundentag
abgeschafft werden muss von arbeitgeberverbänden
Aus der wirtschaft und auch aus der politik zuletzt. Im november vergangenen jahres von den fünf wirtschaftsweisen
Das ist ein beratungsgremium der bundesregierung in einem interview mit der welt, am sonntag sagte dazu der vorsitzende
christoph schmidt firmen die in unserer neuen
Digitalisierten welt bestehen wollen müssen agil sein und schnell ihre teams zusammen rufen können die vorstellung dass man morgens im büro
Den arbeitstag beginnt und mit dem verlassen der firma beendet ist veraltet
Die konkrete forderung lautet nicht die tägliche arbeitszeit auf acht stunden zu begrenzen sondern die maximalzeit von
48 stunden pro woche einzuhalten zudem wird gefordert die ruhezeit von elf auf neun stunden, zu beschränken
Aber ist es nicht höchste zeit flexibler
zu denken denn viele identifizieren sich mit ihrem job können oder wollen
arbeit und privatleben nicht mehr voneinander trennen und der begriff work life balance besteht
Er tatsächlich aus beiden begriffen ganz nach dem motto work gehört für live und andersherum
Zudem ist es beispielsweise in den kreativen branchen lächerlich, zu sagen liebe angestellte ihr müsst um
38 da sein und ab dann auch auf knopfdruck kreativ sein geht das nicht viel besser auf dem balkon oder
im café nebenan
vielleicht ist das auch einer der gründe warum mittlerweile immer mehr unternehmen home office anbieten
Nach einer aktuellen studie sind es trotzdem aber nur noch 16 prozent der arbeitenden bevölkerung die tatsächlich
im home office arbeiten hauptsächlich
liegt dass der befragung zufolge daran dass das natürlich nicht in allen branchen möglich ist weder verkäufer noch paket
Fahren und paketfahrer können eben von zu hause aus arbeiten und auch in anderen bereichen wie etwa
Im krankenhaus macht das absolut keinen sinn da müssen dienstpläne eingehalten werden und auch auf der baustelle ist klar dass man nach acht stunden
spätestens körperlich fertig ist aber
Ist der acht stunden tag nicht, im großen und ganzen schon längst geschichte
fest stehen jedenfalls dieses arbeitsmodell wurde
1918 in deutschland eingeführt aber schon 1932 gab es erste kritik der philosoph
bertrams l war der meinung dass der technologische fortschritt schon bald dazu führen dass die wöchentliche arbeitszeit auf unter
20 stunden reduziert werde als voraussetzung dafür nannte, er gute kommunikation und organisation
auch viele politiker fordern immer mal wieder sechs stunden tage mögliche vorteile liegen auf der hand eine
ausgeglichene
work-life-balance gesteigerte motivation bessere leistungsfähigkeit und und und es gibt zahlreiche
Studien die belegen dass man mit 60 wochenstunden und mehr seine gesundheit es geht immer wieder fordern forschungsteams deswegen eine
25 stunden woche längst sind die zeiten bei vielen vorbei
Als man dem kollegen am fließband die schichtarbeit übergab nach hause gehen und sich entspannte
Eigenverantwortlichkeit, im job ist das stichwort keiner weiß wirklich wie viel wir wirklich arbeiten die zukommt viele unternehmen die vor allem das wissen
ihrer mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter als kapital haben setzen mittlerweile auf vertrauen es ist egal ob zu hause oder im
Büro gearbeitet wird hauptsache das endprodukt stimmt das machen wir übrigens auch hier bei united traders meiner firma die klicks und produziert
Im ausland wie etwa in schweden gibt es einige unternehmen die mit dem sechs stunden tag
experimentieren in tech startups genauso wie in krankenhäusern oder pflegeheimen in der woche kommen die angestellten also auf nur noch 30 statt 40
Stunden aber auch in deutschland tut sich langsam etwas so beispielsweise in einer bielefelder agentur das neue arbeitszeitmodell, sieht
25 wochenstunden vor heiß montags bis freitags von 8 bis 13 uhr kein home office keine erreichbarkeit nach feierabend aber
selbst gehalt und dieselbe anzahl an urlaubstagen der geschäftsführer will damit
Höhere zufriedenheit bei seinen mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern erreichen bei gleichem?
Arbeitsergebnis wo es geht hier um das ergebnis des teams nicht
Um die einzelleistungen e mails werden nur zu bestimmten zeiten gecheckt ansonsten wird fokussiert gearbeitet
und nach der ersten testphase kommen na klar die ersten probleme auf der
Sozialkontakt unter den mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter hat kommt in dieser zeit zu kurz die
personalentwicklung gestaltet sich in fünf stunden schwierig aber der geschäftsführer
Lasse rheingans ist überzeugt von seinem konzept zitat ich glaube an die sache und ich wünsche mir dass die arbeitswelt darüber
diskutiert noch etwas krasser ist das innovative
Arbeitsmodell eines berliner startups hier dürfte jeder am anfang arbeiten wann er will urlaub machen wann und wie lange
Er will von der couch aus arbeiten oder vom strand in thailand mittlerweile
Gibt es diskussionen über die wünsche und ziele des einzelnen
Und des gesamten unternehmens zum beispiel wie hoch soll das gehalt
Seien jetzt steht fest jeder bekommt ein grundgehalt und dazu. Kommen zuschläge je nach erfahrung ausbildung
Lebensumständen und der funktion in der firma immer noch kann jeder so viel urlaub machen wie er will und das wird nicht
Ausgenutzt die mitarbeiter und mitarbeiterinnen nehmen nicht viel mehr frei als früher dafür hat das modell viele vorteile es beweist nicht nur dass
man freizeit und arbeit vereinbaren kann sondern auch persönliche freiheit mit erfolg und karriere
Nach angaben der geschäftsführer ist die motivation der mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter ins unermessliche gestiegen auch in anderen unternehmen weltweit
wurde solch ein arbeitsmodell auf
vertrauensbasis bereits getestet oft mit erfolg es gibt aber auch berichte nach denen das konzept ins gegenteil umgeschlagen ist die mitarbeiter haben sich untereinander
Angestachelt noch mehr zu arbeiten wer urlaub genommen hat wurde als drückeberger abgestempelt davor warnt auch beispielsweise die
industriegewerkschaft bergbau chemie und industrie konkret heißt es wenn beschäftigte immer mehr
freiheiten in der arbeitsgestaltung haben arbeiten sie oft umso länger und härter
flexible formen der arbeitszeitgestaltung führen stadtführer spielräume zur
arbeitszeitverlängerung und zur arbeit intensivierung
Es bleibt also spannend wie sich die arbeit der zukunft entwickelt wenn ihr als erstes neues zum thema arbeit der zukunft
Und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollten dann endet meine telefonnummer whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der redaktion von kling zum mitmachen und mit themen vorschlagen oder
An abstimmungen teilnehmen und somit bestimmen was hier bei pixum passiert der direkte draht zu mir
einfach hier draufklicken und dann geht alles quasi wie von selbst natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Genau vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit auch dafür drauf kriegen die fünf besten methoden zum lernen ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran